bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat c'est jeudi c'est les questions
d'actualité d'actualité aujourd'hui
dominer encore une fois au sénat dans
les couloirs par les propos tenus par
laurent wauquiez sur le rsa beaucoup de
sénateurs se pose la question de la
stratégie de l'ump et notamment après
les propos de jean françois copé qui a
dit que le rsa serait notamment l'un des
curseurs de la campagne de 2012 on
parlera évidemment de cette
problématique
après les questions lors de on refait la
séance aux alentours de 16 heures autre
problématique qui intéresse les français
et qui intéresse beaucoup les sénateurs
la sécheresse la sécheresse qui sévit
actuellement sur la france
le ministre de l'agriculture bruno le
maire va s'exprimer normalement en
milieu d'après midi lors d'une réunion
mais tout de suite direction l'hémicycle
pour la séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente souderait auparavant il nous
rejoindra remercié le président en
roumanie pour l'hommage qu'il a rendue
au début de notre séance d'hier soir
pour nos soldats engagés sur l'ensemble
des théâtres d'opérations extérieures et
de l'avoir fait au nom du sénat tout
entier la parole est à notre collègue
monsieur jack ralite pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et des
sénateurs du parti de gauche
vous avez la parole mais le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre la culture une vive émotion
s'est emparée d'historia et archiviste
annonce de la mise aux enchères le 18
mai par sotheby's décrit de la main de
robespierre entre le 25 janvier 1792 et
le 26 juillet rue est 1794
c'est un véritable trésor mémorielle
gardé par la famille du conventionnel le
banc pendant plus de deux siècles qui
doit absolument intégrer le patrimoine
public
l'action de robespierre homme d'état
hautement responsable dans un moment de
tourner en grand orateur a marqué notre
histoire nationale en profondeur vous
avez été sollicité monsieur le ministre
notamment par la commission des affaires
culturelles du sénat unanime pour faire
barrage à la marchandisation de la
corruptibles trois moyens existent pour
empêcher l'abandon au marché ces
précieux documents acquérir ses lettres
à la vente publique en achat simple
utiliser le droit particulier de l'état
de présenter en vente publique refusé
certificat l'exportation des manuscrits
à ce jour ils sont une employée il faut
aussi l'institution culturelle d'accueil
archives nationales bibliothèque
nationale de france bibliothèque
mazarine ou bibliothèque de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat qui aurait honneur
à recevoir les écrits d'un grand
parlementaire
il faut enfin budget mais le ministère
soumis à la rgpp a réduit les crédits
d'acquisition - 50 % 10 ans ou point
qu'on nous dit manquer d'argent pour
acheter les émouvants écrits de
maximilien robespierre
la mise à prix de sotheby's et de deux
cent à trois cent mille euros
on croira qui croira qu'un ministère
revendiquant un musée de l'histoire de
france ne peut réunir ce crédit qui
permettra la mise en partage d'un grand
moment de notre histoire
comment à de notre histoire et
l'enrichissement de ces sources
aujourd'hui par france domaine et des
nouvelles menaces contre
l'inaliénabilité des oeuvres dans les
musées et archives une politique
démissionnaire et désespérante se déplie
ce tout n'a pas valeur marchande
or la pratique ministériel multiplie les
actes bâti sur elle
l'acquisition des 113 pages le
robespierre est un achat vertueux
l'initiative de la société des études
robespierristes de lancer une
souscription publique et le niveau des
réponses indique l'ampleur citoyenne de
cette démarche
c'est là une grande politesse
républicaine que l'état prenne sa part
sa part légale sa part morale sa part
d'implication responsable qui doit être
inébranlable sa part 2 courtoisie
monsieur le ministre ne laissait pas
faire
un outrage à ce bien commun à ces
documents si éclairant de notre histoire
nationale
il ne reste que six jours pour vous
répondre
la parole est à monsieur patrick ollier
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
vous avez la parole monsieur ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
ministre jacques khalid d'abord je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser l'absence
de frédéric mitterrand qui comme vous le
savez est actuellement au festival de
cannes
je connais et oui fait son métier il
fait son métier de ministre de la
culture je connais monsieur le ministre
comme chacun dans cet hémicycle votre
intérêt et votre grande connaissance des
questions liées au patrimoine historique
et je tiens à ce niveau là vous rendre
hommage robespierre quoi qu'on pense du
personnage fait partie de l'histoire
politique de la france je vous remercie
d'exprimer ici là prix que préoccupation
qui est la vôtre
le gouvernement n'aurait évidemment pas
la vente prévue le 18 mai prochain d'un
ensemble d'archivés concernant
robespierre constitué de brouillon de
discours d'articles et d'une lettre
largement inédits et couvrant la période
de janvier 1792 et juillet 1794
le ministre de culture et la
communication à d'ailleurs demandé à ses
services d'expertisé
cette collection je crois qu il vous l'a
dit ce matin monsieur le ministre
chacun connaît les moyens dont dispose
l'état pour faire en sorte que ces
documents soient mis à la disposition
d'un simple des citoyens vous venez de
les citer je veux pas y revenir
soyez certains que le ministre de la
culture et de la communication est
vigilant et qu'il prendra au nom de
l'état toutes ses responsabilités
je me lis vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure les moyens de l'état et vous
avez dit à ce jour ils ne sont pas
employés mais vous avez dit qu'il
restait encore quelques jours vous
comprendrez que l' usage par l'état de
ses moyens d'intervention nécessite pour
être efficace une certaine discrétion
toute pression politique qui obligerait
l'état a dévoilé ses intentions lors de
la vente porte préjudice à la cause que
vous entendez défendre et que nous
partageons et pourrait également
entraîner à l'accroissement du coût
d'achat de ces manuscrits pour les
finances publiques donc olek
contribuables
ça s'appelle la spéculation voilà
pourquoi je ne dirai rien des
instructions de l'état sioniste
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à notre collègue éric de luge et pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
avait la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministères collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur richert
ministre chargé des collectivités
territoriales
monsieur le ministre le monde est en
totale mutation les entreprises évoluent
à un rythme soutenu
le gouvernement en a tiré la conséquence
qui conduit à la nécessité d'adapter
notre organisation territoriale à notre
temps il a initié un très long débat
commencé en 2009 et achevé en 2010 avec
la loi sur la réforme des collectivités
territoriales permettez-moi une courte
citation du président gérard larcher
l'achèvement de l'intercommunalité qui a
fait l'objet d'un large consensus dans
nos débats et la condition de la
pérennisation du maillage du territoire
national par nos trente six mille 682
communes auquel nous sommes très
attachés
dans l'article de la loi sur
l'intercommunalité voter ici nous avons
défini des règles et décider des délais
les quatre grands principes adoptés sont
simples et claires pas d'interco
inférieur à 5000 habitants sauf
exception couvrir 100% du territoire par
l'interco processus qui vient de débuter
dans le cadre des commissions
départementales ne pas laisser de
communes isolées et réduire quand cela
est possible non des syndicats monsieur
le ministre
dans toutes les lois il ya l'esprit et
la lettre or nous constatons des la mise
en action des commissions que l'esprit
n'est plus là dans une majorité de
départements
certains représentants de l'état font du
zèle et prennent des mesures parfois
maximaliste allant jusqu'à diviser par
deux voire plus le nombre d'interco ce
n'est pas dans la loi et encore moins
dans l'esprit ce n'est ni acceptable ni
tolérable
seul un seul l'interco d'adhésion est
acceptable
monsieur le ministre à la demande du
président du sénat du président de la
mmf du nombre de nombre d'entre nous
vous avez cosigné avec monsieur guéant
ministre une lettre circulaire à tous
les préfets leur demandant je cite de
donner de la souplesse afin de faire
émerger des solutions partagées
bonne nouvelle mais accueillie avec
certaines précautions pour plusieurs
raisons au delà du 31 12 2011 les
membres de la commission intercours
ont-ils toujours le pouvoir d'amendement
quelles sont les conséquences
patrimoniales financières et fiscales
des propositions des schémas et leur
impact en matière de personnel
monsieur le ministre vous avez compris
que 37 mille élus souhaitent que les
schémas se fasse dans le consensus et
non dans la contrainte
le délai n'est pas l'écueil principal
rassurez vous il ya des départements où
l'exercice se passe bien mais sachez
qu'il en est où la révolte gronde
cet exercice ne doit pas être une lutte
entre vos représentants et les élus une
réforme aussi importante et d'une telle
ampleur mérite le plus grand soin merci
de rassurer l'ensemble des élus en
précisant que l'esprit du texte sera
respecté et que la loi ne doit pas être
réécrites hors du parlement
merci mon coeur koné pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur philippe
richert ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales devait la
parole monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs 7 sénateurs eric
doligé j'ai bien compris que vous
exprimer au travers de votre question un
sentiment qui peut trouver écho sur de
nombreux bancs de cette assemblée et au
delà permettez moi simplement de
répondre que nous avons connus déjà
plusieurs étapes dans l'application de
cette loi la première a été tout
simplement la mise en place des
commissions départementales de
l'intercommunalité et nombreux étaient
ceux qui d'ailleurs avait émis un
certain nombre de doutes quant à la mise
en place de ces commissions je veux dire
que globalement ces commissions se sont
mises en place sans difficulté puisque
dans 65% des départements donc environ
il y a eu une seule liste et que dans 5
départements il a eu effectivement vote
mais avec une seule liste aussi donc 70
% des départements donc 70 départements
les choses se sont passées sans élection
et sans difficulté dans 30 départements
il ya eu plusieurs lice mais en général
cela s'est passé aussi sans divulguer et
je me félicite du climat qui a régné
pour la mise en place de ces commissions
départementales aujourd'hui nous sommes
à la présentation par les préfets du
schéma c'est à dire ceux qui a été
élaborée comme étant la base de
discussion
à partir de laquelle on va pouvoir
travailler je voudrais rappeler ici que
d'abord au travers des textes que nous
avons envoyé ensuite au travers des
propos que nous avons vu en direct avec
les préfets et enfin au travers de la
circulaire que nous avons enlevé ou
préfet nous avons rappelé la nécessité
d'établir la concertation la plus
étroite possible avec les élus il s'agit
bien de faire ensemble un travail qui
permettra au travers d'une coproduction
d'arriver au résultat que nous avons
tous souhaité ici je me rappelle qu'au
sénat en particulier il a eu sur tout ce
qui concerne l'intercommunalité comme ça
l'était rappeler une très large
convergence faisant en sorte que nous
puissions travailler avec confiance nous
avons donc rappelé au niveau des préfets
ce souhait exprimé d'aller vers
l'établissement de deux pci qui soit
mieux conforme aux besoins sur le
terrain d'une possibilité d'action
efficaces mais nous avons demandé aussi
que le dialogue soit le plus long
possible et le plus fructueux possible
et nous avons indiqué que s'il y a des
difficultés qui font en sorte que nous
devions dépassé la date limite du 31
décembre
eh bien nous aurons l'occasion de
l'examiner parce qu'il s'agit de faire
en sorte que sur autant de sujets que
possible nous plions puissions
travailler de façon convergente entre
d'un côté les représentants de l'état à
savoir les préfets et de l'autre côté
les élus locaux sur le terrain voilà ce
que je souhaitais dire monsieur le
sénateur à votre question très précise
merci monsieur le ministre à paroles est
un monsieur jean michel baylet pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise affaires
européennes et concerne absence de plus
en plus fade flagrante d'unité de
solidarité et de volonté politique de
l'union les egan pris dans l'actualité
ne manquent pas et je n'en citerai que
trois
notre voisin allemand décide d'arrêter
ses centrales nucléaires
sans même consulter ses partenaires
européens
or une telle décision nous le savons est
lourde de conséquences
sur la politique énergétique de l'union
et sur l'approvisionnement énergétique
de chacun de ses membres
faut-il rappeler que la construction
européenne à commencer qu'une politique
énergétique commune la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier
désormais nous tournons le dos à cette
volonté autre sujet la syrie est
toujours la même impuissance pour
affirmer une volonté politique forte
l'europe adoptent certes des sanctions
mais timide et a minima paris londres et
berlin ne parvenant pas à convaincre
leurs partenaires de la nécessité
d'inclure le numéro un syrien tristement
célèbre par les temps qui courent est
dans l'actualité sur la lisez
personnalité concernée par le gel des
avoirs et des interdictions de visas
d'entrée dans l'union européenne
sur un tel sujet touchante autres
valeurs fondatrices de l'europe à savoir
le respect des droits de l'homme
il n'est pas acceptable que l'on fasse
preuve d'autant de frilosité et d'un tel
manque de volontarisme
quand l'europe parlant des langues fin
d'une seule et même voix d'une loi ferme
et sans ambiguïté
face aux despotes et aux tirs en
troisième exemple très différents c'est
la suppression de la grande bretagne des
crédits du remorquage est en charge de
la sécurité maritime à manches à partir
30 septembre
cette zone à très haut risque va perdre
son remorqueur de haute mer près
intervenir 24h 24 pour ce gros gilet
bateau en difficulté
jusque-là ce navire était affrété
conjointement par la grande bretagne et
la france
or notre voisin a décidé de mettre un
terme à sa participation et nous a
placés devant le fait accompli décision
inacceptable puisque nous savons que 200
millions de tonnes de matières
dangereuses transitent par ce détroit et
surtout que un quart de nos capacités
nucléaires se situe sur ce littoral
5 chacun sait que flamanville gravelines
sont des centrales refroidi à eau de mer
qu'arrivera-t-il s'il y avait des nappes
de pétrole à la dérive
comment monsieur le ministre la france
en dentelle faire face sachant que les
spécialistes savent très bien que nous
sommes beaucoup plus exposés que les
années alors monsieur le ministre
l'europe est en panne l'europe est en
crise c'est les arbres ses états membres
se reprit sur eux-mêmes et le principe
pourtant fondateur
de solidarité s'est remise en cause de
toute part quelles initiatives monsieur
misa phrase propose-t-elle pour donner
force et unités à une europe qui a tant
besoin de coordination et de célérité et
devant un tel enjeu ne croyez vous pas
monsieur le ministre
conduisez mieux à faire que de montrer
du doigt stigmatiser les français les
plus fragiles
je veux parler bien sûr des allocataires
du revenu de solidarité active pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur
laurent wauquiez mais les charges et les
affaires européennes la parole monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le président baylet vos
convictions pro européennes sont connues
et elles sont respectées je voudrais
juste à travers votre question que nous
puissions refaire l'évolution qui s'est
fait depuis quatre ans sur le front
européen
prenons la situation il ya quatre ans
une europe qui n'avait plus de traiter
une europe qui n'avait plus de capacité
de décision
une europe qui était en difficulté sur
des sujets majeurs tels que l'euro
observons ensemble en quatre ans avec
les initiatives qui ont été portées par
le président de la république et la
majorité
les avancées qui ont été faites sur les
sujets les uns après les autres
un traité le traité de lisbonne qui a
permis de sortir de l'impasse du traité
de constitutionnel la présidence
française qui notamment au moment de la
géorgie a permis de montrer la capacité
de l'europe à réagir collectivement
l'euro euros qui n'avaient pas de
mécanisme de défense et de solidarité et
qui malgré les réticences des uns et des
autres a permis de se doter pour la
première fois pour défendre notre
monnaie commune contre les spéculations
qui visait la fragiliser d'un outil de
défense communs gouvernance économique
sujet pour lequel vous même vous avez
souvent plaidé
et d'ailleurs qui comporte les sujets
sociaux monsieur baylet et qui
permettront aussi d'aborder des
thématiques telles que la cohésion
sociale ou la valorisation du travail où
les questions de formation
professionnelle convergence fiscale
enfin sujet monsieur baylet pour lequel
aussi vous aviez souvent plaidé et qui
connaîtra une première avancée avec la
possibilité d'une coordination des bases
de l'impôt sur les sociétés j'ajouterai
enfin un point sur lequel on vous a
également souvent entendu intervenir
la question de la réciprocité dans notre
politique commerciale et notamment dans
nos rapports avec la chine reste bien
sûr des sujets plus difficiles sur
lesquels l'europe ces derniers temps a
eu plus de mal à afficher un front
commun
je pense d'abord à la question de la
libye sur lequel le ministre d'état
alain juppé s'est battue sans relâche
l'europe a d'abord permis d'avoir un
certain nombre de positions communes
fortes en matière de sanction pour le
reste sur l'application de la résolution
vous le savez il ya eu des divergences
entre la france et l'allemagne mais
mesures ont là encore le chemin qui a
été parcouru entre une europe
impuissante qui s'était révélé à
srebrenica et al'inverse la capacité à
avoir réagi malgré tout sur ce qui s'est
passé en libye
je reviendrai enfin sur ce que vous avez
dit sur l'énergie en matière nucléaire
les différentes options restent des
choix qui appartiennent aux états
membres par contre l'union européenne
avant même les graves incidents de
fukushima avait pris des positions
communes en promouvant les plus hauts
standards de sécurité non seulement pour
l'europe pour ses voisins mais aussi à
l'échelle du monde monsieur baylet je
vous rejoint l'europe traversent des
crises mais malgré ces crises l'europe
avance et l'europe politique n'a jamais
autant progressé au cours des quatre
dernières années et ce sera un des
points de bilan solide du président de
la république
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant le pr collègue
madame jacqueline gourault pour le
groupe de l'union centriste avait la
parole mais chers collègues
douloureuse et monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales
mes chers collègues au moment où les
préfets présente les schémas
départementaux de coopération
intercommunale et alors que les députés
viennent de voter le projet de loi
consacré uniquement au nombre de
conseillers territoriaux
suite à la censure de l'article 6 de la
loi de 2010 il m'a semblé opportun de
revenir sur la réforme des collectivités
territoriales afin de vous poser
plusieurs questions première question
monsieur le ministre pourquoi justement
avoir commencé à l'assemblée nationale
la première lecture de cette loi sur le
tableau de répartition des conseillers
territoriaux
n'aurait-il pas été logique voire
constitutionnel de commencer par le
sénat deuxième question
deuxième question que devient la loi qui
doit mettre en place ce système de
fléchage pour l'élection coco me tente
au suffrage universel des conseillers
communautaires et des conseillers
municipaux et bien sûr en même temps et
conséquemment le niveau du seuil à
partir duquel le scrutin de liste sera
obligatoire troisième question alors que
près de 60 projets départementaux de
coopération intercommunale sont parus je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur
plusieurs points bien évidemment je ne
ferai pas de commentaire sur ces projets
par département mais monsieur le
ministre je voulais simplement vous dire
faites attention à ce que les élus
soient bien associés c'est là un peu la
question de mon collègue doligé tout à
l'heure car je suis sûr que comme moi
vous savez que la réforme ne peut pas se
faire sans eux
ou plus grave encore contre eux je me
permet d'ailleurs de citer les propos du
président du sénat gérard larcher
j'ai reçu ce matin bah oui j'ai reçu une
lettre du président ce matin vous
permettez que je cite la consécration de
la commune comme coeur de notre
démocratie locale conduit à privilégier
une intercommunalité d'adhésion aussi
monsieur le ministre si monsieur le
ministre
voudriez vous me dire s'il vous plaît je
peux poser mes questions
aussi monsieur le ministre vous voudriez
vous me dire ce qui se passe car à mon
avis le texte mérite d'être explicite et
c'est une majorité des deux tiers n'est
pas obtenue pour modifier la carte
présentée par le préfet doit-il
présenter un nouveau projet à la cdc y
quatrième que ce point va falloir
rapidement je sais je vais je vais
terminer mais allez voir c'est très
important
la fusion des communautés semble avoir
été choisie comme règle assez fréquentes
par les préfets et je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur une difficulté
majeure
monsieur le ministre pour la mise en
place de ces nouveaux opci
en effet en cas de fusion l'application
de la loi est immédiate
en ce qui concerne la mise en oeuvre du
tableau du nombre de conseillers
communautaires ainsi que le plafonnement
de l'exécutif ou complaisances président
monsieur le ministre alors que le
gouvernement souhaite une réforme
constructive
vous mesurez bien que ces paramètres
compliquer la mise en place de ces
fusions autant après un renouvellement
général des ministres mais c'est
important non au temps au temps après un
renouvellement général des élus
municipaux et communautaires et les
facile d'expliquer d'appliquer les
nouvelles règles autant en cours de
mandat il est difficile de changer les
règles du jeu il va falloir en effet
vraiment que vous vous penchiez sur ce
sujet monsieur le ministre ce que je
vais te tuer réalité allez monsieur le
ministre en moins de 2 minutes 30 pour
vous pencher là dessus
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice jacqueline gourault voilà
quatre ray questions complémentaires la
question de monsieur doligé de tout à
l'heure je vais donc essayer de répondre
très rapidement j'ai déjà dit le
l'esprit dans lequel ça fonctionne comme
précisé en quelques mots pour dire qu'au
niveau de la mise en place des
commissions départementales ça s'est
bien passé et les discussions la plupart
du temps ont bien démarré au niveau des
commissions départementales quelques
débats parfois un peu houleux mais
globalement ça s'est bien passé alors
sur les quatre questions qui vont être
posées va donc essayer de répondre de
façon la plus précise et la plus rapide
possible
premièrement pourquoi est ce que nous
avons présenté le projet de loi fixant
les effectifs des conseillers
territoriaux
d'abord à l'assemblée nationale pour
répondre tout simplement que parce que
ce texte ne porte pas sur l'organisation
des collectivités territoriales mais sur
le nombre de circonscriptions d'élection
du nouveau conseiller territorial il ya
une jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel
désormais bien fixé sur ce point le
deuxième point vous le savez et vous le
savez aussi bien que moi c'est que le
tableau avait été introduit à
l'assemblée nationale hélas paru logique
comme il a été introduit à l'assemblée
nationale pas de le présenter d'abord en
discussion au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale le deuxième point que vous
avez évoquées concernent l'avenir du
projet de loi relatifs à l'élection des
conseillers territoriaux et au
renforcement de la démocratie locale
ce qu'on appelle le projet de loi numéro
60 yolk et le dernier étage de ce qu'on
appelle la fusée réforme des
collectivités territoriales alors ceci
ce texte est sur le bureau et a été
déposée sur le bureau
au bureau du sénat il est évident qu'il
sera débattu par la haute assemblée dès
que l'agenda parlementaire le père m'a
trahi en tout état de cause dans un
calendrier cohérent avec la mise en
oeuvre effective de conseiller
territorial en 2014
vous avez notamment posé à ce sujet la
question
du seuil en ce qui concerne les
élections au scrutin de liste je veux
redire ici ce qui a déjà été dit par le
président de la république et le premier
ministre à savoir que le seuil actuel
qui est prévu dans le texte qui est de
500 habitants est bien le gouvernant
déjà fait savoir qu'il ne s'opposerait
pas à ce que le parlement à savoir le
sénat l'assemblée nationale puisse
revoir ce texte à 1000 ou 1500 ce sont
des chiffres qui donc déjà été indiqué
le troisième fois je continue vous me
demandez ensuite ce qui se passera si le
schéma départemental de coopération
intercommunale arrêté par le préfet
rencontre d opposition sérieuse au
moment de sa mise en oeuvre
j'ai déjà expliqué tout à l'heure en
réponse à monsieur doligé qu'il est
possible dans des situations de blocage
d'aller au delà du 31 décembre 2011
mais je veux dire aussi que la loi
prévoit que jusqu'au 1er juin 2013
le préfet aura la possibilité de s'en
écarter si cela est nécessaire pour
créer un le pci cohérent en termes de
périmètre de compétence ou de ressources
le préfet devrait alors consulté la
commission départementale de coopération
intercommunale qui pourra modifier le
projet du préfet à la majorité des deux
tiers pour être très précis dans la
réponse
la dernière chose si cela nécessaire à
moi que je le fasse tout à l'heure si
j'ai encore intervenir donc c'est ce qui
concerne les responsabilités c'est clair
que entre le 1er juin 2013 donc date
ultime de mise en oeuvre de la réforme à
savoir notamment la fusion des epc et le
le printemps 2014 qui sera la future
élection au niveau des conseillers
municipaux et donc des opci et bien il
ya une période d'un peu moins d'une
année pendant laquelle il est vrai entre
les anciens conseillers communautaires
et les nouveaux conseillers
communautaires
il y aura des besoins d'ajustement c'est
vrai que dans les nouveaux dispositifs
il n'y a que quinze vice-présidents
possible mais il sera possible d'avoir
des membres de conseils communautaires
avec délégation dont pour compléter la
présentation sur l'as nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir si vous le
permettez bien mes chers collègues
on va essayer de se reprendre au point
de vue du temps la parole est maintenant
monsieur claude jeannerot cours
le groupe socialiste et pour 2 minutes
30 je demande à sa merci
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question était initialement
destiné à monsieur le premier ministre
au début de cette semaine un ministre de
votre gouvernement annonçait le dépôt
d'une proposition de loi
je le cite pour que les allocataires du
rsa soit obligé d'accomplir un travail
d'intérêt général non rémunéré et pour
que le total des minima sociaux pour que
le total des minima sociaux ne puissent
dépasser 75 % du smi ces propos mes
chers collègues vise d'abord à faire
croire aux français qu'il est possible
de gagner plus avec le rsa qu'avec un
revenu du travail
c'est faux le rsa ne le permet pas il y
a une différence de 660 euros entre le
rsa et le smic
comment peut-on s'en prendre ainsi aux
plus pauvres et tenter d'opposer ceux
qui ont un peu à ceux qui n'ont rien
nous aurions préféré entendre cette
vertueuse indignation sur le bonus des
banquiers
jusqu'à quatre millions et demi pour
l'un d'eux à mettre en face du rsa 460
euros par mois et pour faire bonne
mesure et pour faire bonne mesure ce
ministre propose aussi que les étrangers
ne puissent pas bénéficier des minima
sociaux s'ils ne sont pas depuis cinq
ans au moins en france
mais mes chers collègues c'est déjà le
cas l'article 3 de la loi rsa la ainsi
prévu alors pourquoi revenir sur une
telle question à quoi joue-t-on affirmé
que le rsa concurrence le travail est
bien entendu contraire à l'esprit même
du rsa mais c'est méconnaître surtout la
réalité quotidienne vécue par nos
concitoyens les plus en difficulté mes
chers collègues ne demande ni la charité
ni l'assistance et le travail
obligatoire n'est évidemment pas la
réponse
ils veulent un vrai emploi un vrai
travail qui leur permette de vivre
dignement et décemment avec leur famille
et c'est pour ça que nous élus locaux
nous mettons en place dans nos
départements
les actions d'accompagnement et de
formation nécessaire mais vous en
conviendrez nos efforts n'ont de chance
d'aboutir que si la croissance et
l'emploi sont au rendez vous c'est là la
principale condition mais c'est d'abord
la première responsabilité de votre
gouvernement
or les problèmes demeurent force est de
le constater
chômage précarité manque de logements et
désigner les plus pauvres d'entre nous à
la vindicte n'est pas digne et ne résout
rien nos valeurs républicaines en
coupure nos valeurs républicaines
la fraternité notamment sont gravement
mises en cause ma question est simple et
elle s'adresse au premier ministre
quelles suites envisagez vous de donner
à la proposition de votre ministre sur
le rsa je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame roselyne
bachelot narquin ministre des
solidarités et de la cohésion sociale
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur claude
jeannerot le gouvernement a fait de la
lutte contre la pauvreté un des
objectifs majeurs de sa politique
pour cela il a procédé à des mesures de
revalorisation de l'ensemble des minima
sociaux sans précédent
je veux rappeler quelques chiffres c'est
ainsi que pendant le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy sera augmenté de 25%
l'allocation d'adulte handicapé qui
passe de 621 euros à 776 euros
cela concerne neuf cent mille personnes
de la même façon le minimum vieillesse a
été augmentée de la même façon et cela
concerne 600 mille personnes quant au
revenu de solidarité active
il constitue une des avancées sociales
majeures du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
et nous voulons le conforter et le
protéger il a permis de mieux rémunérer
les allocataires qui acceptaient de
passer à une activité salariée c'est
ainsi que ses allocataires touche en
moyenne 170 euros supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire deux mois de smic
creusant ainsi l'écart entre un revenu
d'inactivité et un revenu et un revenu
d'activité
et nous avons ainsi sortie 210 mille
personnes de la pauvreté grâce au
système du rsa et c'est un système
souple puisque il y à un flux de 80000
personnes qui rentrent et qui sort du
dispositif
chaque mois donc ce système est
perfectible bien sûr et nous nous à nous
nous y employons
c'est ainsi que effectivement cette
période de crise de sortie de crise il
faut augmenter les mécanismes
d'insertion il était un peu normal que
cette insertion professionnelle soit
moins réalisé que leur revenu de
subsistance était tout à fait c'était
tout à fait compréhensible il faut
simplifier le dispositif
et puis il y a quelque chose qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur
la monoparentalité devenu un facteur
massif d'exclusion et de pauvreté et
avec les caisses d'allocations
familiales
je m'attache à trouver les dispositifs
qui vont permettre de sortir ces
familles monoparentales de notes la
pauvreté et de la précarité
oui je regrette peut-être monsieur
jeannerot que vous n'ayez pas cru bon de
voter ce dispositif du rsa quand il a
été présenté votre critique serait plus
substantiel est plus justifiée
le rsa est une grande avancée du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
nous en sommes fiers et nous allons le
conforter merci madame la ministre la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
christian cambon pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur alain juppé ministre d'état
ministre des affaires étrangères et
européennes dans le lent et difficile
mouvement qui agite actuellement le
monde arabe
les événements récents en libye et en
syrie nous montre avec quelle force et
au prix de quels sacrifices ces peuples
veulent marcher vers la démocratie
et pourtant les pays de la vieille
europe semble adopter une attitude très
différente
face à ces révolutions en libye les
opérations aériennes
en application de la résolution 1973 du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
neutralisent
jour après jour les forces du colonel
kadhafi qui tentent de réduire au
silence l'opposition
la france a engagé des forces navales et
aériennes conséquente et apporte sa
contribution dans le respect et la
stricte exécution des directives de
l'onu afin de hâter les solutions
politiques seule issue à cette situation
mais au même moment en syrie si proche
de notre chère liban les aspirations
populaires exprime avec la même
intensité qu'en libye leur soif de
démocratie
or nous assistons là impuissant à une
répression féroce et sanglante de la
part du gouvernement syrien
nous constatons hélas que les membres de
l'union européenne peine à trouver des
réponses et à mettre en oeuvre des
sanctions susceptible d'interrompre ces
massacres
la france par votre voix à monsieur le
ministre d'état a regretté le manque de
sévérité de ces sanctions adoptées
récemment par nos partenaires européens
nous le savons la syrie assure un rôle
particulier dans la stabilité et la paix
au proche-orient notamment pour la
résolution du conflit israélo
palestinien dont elle est évidemment
partie prenante toutefois jusqu où
pourra-t-on tolérer le massacre de ceux
qui rêvent de démocratie et comment
expliquer aux opinions française et
européenne
cette différence de traitement entre les
deux pays
alors monsieur le ministre d'état pouvez
vous indiquer à notre assemblée
quelles initiatives la france en
relation avec ses voisins européens
peut-elle prendre pour faire cesser ces
exactions et ouvrir la voie à une
solution politique
seul chemin dans cette région pour
conduire à la paix et à la démocratie
merci mon cher collègue vous répondre la
parole est à monsieur alain juppé
ministre d'état ministre des affaires
étrangères et européennes nous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre d'état
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur cambon votre
question me permet de réaffirmer de
manière solennelle que la france ne fait
pas deux poids et deux mesures quand il
s'agit de l'aspiration des peuples à la
liberté du respect des droits de l'homme
et de la marche vers la démocratie et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
affirmé très clairement que la
répression en syrie étaient intolérables
et ne devait pas être toléré nous avons
commencé par demander aux autorités
syriennes de tenir compte de ces
aspirations populaires et de s'engager
dans un programme de réformes ambitieux
nos appels n'ont pas été entendus et le
gouvernement syrien a choisi tout au
contraire une répression sauvage les
morts ce chiffre par plusieurs centaines
aujourd'hui des tanks ont été utilisées
contre des manifestations populaires et
c'est inacceptable
alors ne sommes pas contentée de
condamner nous avons tout fait pour agir
d'abord dans l'instance suprême qui
décide de la paix ou de la guerre au
niveau mondial à savoir le conseil de
sécurité nous avons préparé avec nos
amis britanniques un projet de
résolution condamnant la répression en
syrie
les conditions aujourd'hui ne sont pas
réunies pour que ce projet de résolution
soit votée et cela pour au moins trois
raisons d'abord parce que deux membres
permanents ont fait savoir qu'ils s'y
opposeraient
ensuite parce que les pays arabes ne se
sont pas engagés comme il l'avait fait
pour le vote de la résolution 1973
concernant la syrie et en troisième lieu
parce que la majorité des neuf fois
nécessaire au vote d'une résolution
n'est pas aujourd'hui réunies
nous ne renonçons
nous continuons à travailler au conseil
de sécurité j'ai contacté hier tout
récemment encore mon collègue brésilien
ma collègue sud africaine pour les
convaincre de nous aider dans cette voie
nous avons ensuite agit au niveau du
conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies
d'abord en obtenant la condamnation de
la syrie par ce conseil des droits de
l'homme et l'envoi d'une mission
d'enquêté en syrie ensuite en prenant
l'initiative pour éviter ce qui nous
menace et que la syrie ne soit élu dans
ce conseil de sécurité je me réjouis
aujourd'hui le koweït est présenté sa
candidature et quincy la syrie puissent
être écartés
et puis enfin devant la difficulté
d'obtenir des résultats
à new york nous avons agi au niveau
européen je ne peux pas laisser dire que
l'europe n'a rien fait nous avons pris
des décisions cette semaine d'abord la
décision d'un embargo sur les armes
décision dans destination de la syrie
ensuite la révision de notre politique
de coopération avec la syrie
on ne laissant subsister que les
programmes qui peuvent bénéficier à la
population et enfin l'inscription sur
une liste de 13 personnalités syriennes
qui seront frappés d'interdiction de
déplacement ou de gel de leurs avoirs
financiers
nous aurions souhaité que sur cette
liste figure à le président bachar al
assad
nos partenaires ont estimé que c'était
encore prématuré et qu'il fallait
prendre du temps nous ne renonçons pas
arriver à ce résultat
voilà ce que nous avons fait et nous
continuons notre travail de conviction
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse se dire que
dans ce domaine la diplomatie française
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république n'ait pas été cohérente et
volontaire merci monsieur le ministre
d'état
la parole est maintenant madame nicole
bricq pour le groupe socialiste avait la
parole mes chers collègues
la confrontation avec l'actualité est
rude pour le gouvernement quand dans le
même temps il s'attaque aux plus faibles
au travers des velléités de certains de
ses membres au travers du rsa
précisément et
en même temps ils gardent une certaine
complaisance vis-à-vis des rémunérations
des hauts dirigeants des établissements
bancaires et financiers
et pourtant les uns et les autres ici
nous avions en octobre 2008 porter un
diagnostic commun les rémunérations
exorbitantes dans le domaine de la
finance et de la banque avait entraîné
des prises de risques irresponsables qui
avait abouti à ce que la partie
développés de la planète subissent une
crise dont nous ne sommes pas sortis
et justement quand le gouvernement a
demandé aux parlementaires d'apporter le
soutien de la nation au travers de leur
vote en octobre 2008 pour que les
banquiers les banques les établissements
financiers puissent bénéficier de prêts
et de garanties de l'état
nous avons été les uns et les autres
prêts à le faire et seulement une partie
de l'hémicycle a demandé des
contreparties
le groupe socialiste avait demandé des
contreparties en matière de rémunération
alors madame la ministre de l'économie
et des finances a pris un arrêté pour
transposer une directive européenne qui
conduisait à une certaine complaisance
vis-à-vis des établissements financiers
et bancaires puisque ont passé d'une
directive européenne où la volonté du
législateur était très clair les
rémunérations devait être équilibré
entre la partie variable et la partie
fixe et ça s'est traduit c'est peut-être
une erreur de traduction en approprier
alors est-ce que c'est approprié que le
président directeur général de la banque
la bpce touche un million six pour 2010
et que la part variable soit 2 66% et
que je n'ai pris que ces deux là parce
que ces deux anciens collaborateurs du
président de la république et que le pdg
de la société générale lui tout quatre
millions trois dont une part variable de
77% alors il paraît que le président de
la république s'est ému de cette
situation
si j'en crois la presse et il a dit il
faut faire quelque à son gouvernement il
faut faire quelque chose pour les
conclusions lundi il avait déjà dit en
février 2008 que l'autorégulation et les
rémunérations excessives c'était fini et
bien non les affaires reprennent donc
monsieur le ministre du budget vous avez
présenté hier à la commission des
finances du sénat une loi de finances
rectificative on évoque donc vous avez
un véhicule sous la main pourquoi
attendre faites-le comme les socialistes
voulons régulièrement proposées soit par
plafonnement soit par taxation
dissuasive et pour vous parler -
ministre du budget et des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur madame briques
le président de la république est à
l'origine de l'ensemble des conditions
de réglementation internationale qui
vise à tirer les leçons de la grande
crise mondiale dont une partie provient
en effet d'un excès d'une cupidité de la
part de traders qui ont joué avec
l'argent des autres et qui entraînait la
crise bancaire que nous avons connues
c'est en effet à pittsburgh nous vous
déplaisent de cette situation à la
brique c'est en effet à pittsburgh que
le président de la république a souhaité
que le g20 mettent en place un
dispositif de régulation concernant les
benêts les bonus et l'équilibré de ces
rémunérations entre les parts variables
et les parts fixes
c'est ensuite le président de la
république avec l'énergie de la ministre
de l'économie christine lagarde que la
commission européenne a adopté un
dispositif de régulation européenne
concernant l'encadrement de ces
rémunérations
la france à transposer cette directive
européenne le porte parole du
commissaire barnier a donné
le feu vert pour cette transposition et
nous sommes maintenant dans un état de
droit qui depuis le début de la
législature avait été moi de vous le
rappeler est passé par la loi tepa avec
une taxation additionnelles sur les
stocks options puis des obligations pour
le mandataire social d'assurer la
transparence de sa rémunération
puis au cours de la loi de finances 2011
le gouvernement a pris l'initiative de
doubler les cotisations sociales
concernant les retraites chapeau
faut-il aller plus loin il est
incontestable que la situation actuelle
de la distribution des bonus et le
décalage qui peut exister entre la part
variable et la part fixe nourrit la
réflexion au sein de la majorité
nourri la réflexion au sein du
gouvernement
je veux dire que nous souhaitons
travailler dans le cadre d'une justice
sociale
je veux dire aussi que nous souhaitons
mieux encadrer naturellement des
dispositifs qui peuvent heurter
légitimement le contrat social qui nous
lie c'est la raison pour laquelle oui
nous réfléchissons à des modalités
pratiques sur les très hauts salaires
nous n'ouvrons pas pour autant la porte
dans le cadre de la réforme fiscale sur
une tranche marginale de l'impôt sur le
revenu car il ne s'agit pas de
transférer une fiscalité du patrimoine
sur une fiscalité du travail mais nous
ouvrons le débat en effet sur la
problématique des très hauts salaires
pour que ce soit plus juste plus
équilibrée et donc plus acceptés par la
société tout en à terme
merci monsieur la parole est maintenant
président adrien gouteyron pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président ce le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresser au
ministre de l'agriculture l'aménagement
du territoire et de la pêche
elle veut en effet appelé l'attention du
gouvernement sur une préoccupation qui
départage je crois beaucoup de nos
compatriotes puisque je veux parler de
la sécheresse
selon météo france le mois d'avril a été
le plus chaud depuis 1900 chers
collègues et le risque de voir se
reproduire la situation de 76 que
beaucoup d'entre nous un an
ted est très grand je me me faire ici
l'écho de ceux qui souffrent de cette
situation absolument exceptionnel et qui
subissent de plein fouet cette
sécheresse bien entendu les agriculteurs
et notamment les éleveurs
je pense pouvoir m'exprimer au nom d'un
certain nombre de mes collègues de tous
les départements car je crois la plupart
des départements sont touchés par cette
situation
la situation hydrologique dans mon
département la haute loire est
particulièrement préoccupante elle
affecte l'ensemble du département
je veux dire que le le fourrage va
manquer il manque déjà dans beaucoup
d'exploitations les éleveurs vont être
conduits à acheter ce fourrage
or un prix très élevé or beaucoup
d'entre eux en sont tout à fait
incapable la situation financière est
très très leur situation financière est
très dégradé leur trésorerie est exemple
et les la situation des exploitations ne
permet donc pas ses achats en dernier
recours il est certain que beaucoup
d'entre eux seront reconduits à
décapitaliser et c'est dramatique
quant aux céréales elles sont très
touchées on le sait la germination des
maïs ne serait pas la croissance de
l'orge d'hiver et déblais très faible
quant à l'herbe
les troupes ont été mis en pacage au
moins un mois avant la date habituelle
et l'herbe ne repousse pas beaucoup
d'exploitations ont commencé leurs
travaux dans sillage avec des semaines
la danse et le rendement de 7 ans il a
géré lui parfois des deux tiers le monde
agricole souffre depuis de nombreuses
années on le sait et certaines
exploitations sont au bord de l'asphyxié
je crois savoir que le gouvernement va
réunir lundi prochain un comité
sécheresse
pouvez vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre ce qui est envisagé pour
répondre à l'urgence immédiate de cette
situation
qu'entend faire le gouvernement pour
répondre à la détresse de beaucoup de
nos compatriotes
merci monsieur le président pour vous
répondre la parole est un monsieur
benoist apparu secrétaire d'état vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président gottéron
nous venons de connaître vous venez de
l'évoquer un mois d'avril qui est selon
les relevés de météo france
parmi les plus secs depuis 1959
en avril les précipitations ont été
trois fois moins importante que la
normale
il a fait plus chaud de 4 degrés et
malgré les pluies de l'automne 2010 nous
allons donc démarrer une saison estivale
avec des nappes phréatiques qui ne sont
pas recharger et une sécheresse
importante des sols superficiels comme
vous pouvez le connaître dans votre
département
nathalie kosciusko morizet était
évidemment particulièrement vigilante
sur ce sujet nous avons pris de l'ordre
déjà en nombre de décisions sur le plan
départemental les préfets prennent dès à
présent des mesures de restriction en
commençant bien évidemment par les
usages les moins prioritaires à savoir
le remplissage des piscines privées ou
le lavage des voitures
l'objectif pour nous est évidemment de
gérer au mieux la ressource pour
privilégier les usages économiques de
cette ressource
une vingtaine de départements sont
d'ores et déjà concernés sur le plan
national la ministre a décidé de réunir
dès lundi prochain la commission de
suivi hydrologique du comité national de
l'eau dit comité sécheresse afin de
faire un point sur l'état des sols et
des nappes et sur les mesures envisagées
du côté de l'agriculture
les enjeux sont évidemment tout aussi
important et bruno le maire est inquiet
pour les grandes cultures et pour
l'élevage
d'ores et déjà il a pris un certain
nombre de mesures il est d'ores
désormais possible d'utiliser les hr
sans restriction concernant la paille
enjeu important que vous avez soulevés
il faut bien évidemment joué à plein la
solidarité pour qu'elle puisse être
réservés en priorité aux éleveurs
on ne peut d'ailleurs que se féliciter d
initiative prise en la matière par la
fnsea
des contrats de vente de paille entre
départements enfin vous évoqué le
problème des assurances notamment d
assurance récolte
cette suspension ne concerne je vous le
rappelle que les nouveaux souscripteurs
les agriculteurs qui procède au
renouvellement renouvellement de leur
contrat ont la possibilité de le faire
jusqu'au 15 mai mais bien évidemment le
ministre de l'agriculture restent
vigilants pour que les pratiques
commerciales les assureurs respecte et
évidemment la réglementation en vigueur
comme vous le voyez nathalie kosciusko
morizet bruno le maire travaille
évidemment de concert pour permettre une
meilleure gestion de la ressource donner
la visibilité et notamment en premier
lieu à la profession agricole
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue michel teston pour le
groupe socialiste
deux minutes trente neuf et les paroles
mon cher collègue merci monsieur le
président la poste annoncé récemment le
lancement au 1er octobre prochain d'une
nouvelle offre dite de courrier rapide
cycle pour les particuliers et les
entreprises
angie +2 dans son communiqué la poste
précise vouloir réduire ainsi son
empreinte écologique et garantir un
niveau de fiabilité et de qualité de
service plus élevé toujours selon la
poste
le nouveau service est censée s'inscrire
dans une optique de développement
durable en limitant transport aérien à
la corse et odom la nouvelle offre se
veut aussi plus économique avec un
nouveau timbre au prix de 57 centimes
quel que soit le soin apporté par la
poste a justifié cette refonte hautement
symbolique de son offre il n'en demeure
pas moins qu'il s'agit de mettre en
place un courrier à deux vitesses pour
favoriser
la distribution à j + 2 en effet le prix
du nouveau timbre et en plus bas que
celui du thème habituel qui va passer à
60 centimes au 1er juillet prochain le
nombre de courriers distribués à j + 2
va très probablement fortement augmenté
le risque est donc réel d'un vrai recul
en matière d'acheminement du courrier
par rapport à la situation actuelle
certes imparfaite mais où plus de 83%
des lettres prioritaires sont distribués
à j + 1 je vous rappelle qu'à la demande
du chef de l'état la majorité
présidentielle a voté en 2009 la
transformation de la poste en société
anonyme
ouvrant ainsi la voie à l'entrée
ultérieure d'actionnaires privés dans le
capital de la poste
le gouvernement va-t-il maintenant
avaliser un nouvel affaiblissement du
service public postal
en acceptant que la distribution du
courrier à j + 2 devienne à terme la
règle opposé à cette évolution
prévisible
le groupe socialiste du sénat attend une
réponse claire à cette question et bien
pour vous répondre la parole à monsieur
pierre lellouche secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce extérieur vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur michel teston vous
le savez la loi du 9 février 2010 à
renforcer la présence postale sur le
territoire avec
avec l'obligation avec l'obligation
désormais inscrite dans la loi de
maintenir également mais également dans
le 9e mais absolument monsieur le
sénateur joe merci de reconnaître qu'il
y à là d'ailleurs une poste centrale
riches auront dans le 9e c'est bien là
la maintenir à ne maintenir donc un
réseau postal voyez que je connais un
tout petit peu la poste réseau postal
constitué d'au moins dix sept mille
points de contact dix sept mille points
de contact 90% de la population monsieur
testons 90% de la population est situé à
moins de 5 km d'un point de contact
notamment en ardèche monsieur testons la
part de la population distance de plus
de 5 km du réseau postal
quant à elle la distance qui les sépare
de ce réseau ne serait dépassé 20
minutes de trajet automobile
au total ce dispositif a été complété
comme vous le savez par un contrat de
présence postale territoriale signé en
janvier 2011 entre l'état l'association
des maires de france et la poche il a
accru la contribution financière de
l'état qui est passé à 170 millions
d'euros et 1 et un décret et un décret
venant spécifié cette compétence est
cette part de l'état est en ce moment
sur le point d'être signé il est
présenté à la commission européenne par
le conseil d'état
ce contrat prévoit de maintenir dans
chaque département un nombre de points
de contact en zone prioritaire notamment
dans les communes rurales
il est aussi précisé il est aussi
précisé que les horaires d'ouverture ne
peuvent pas être modifiées monsieur
testons vous le savez vous avez je crois
travailler sur ce sujet sans l'accord
sans l'accord du maire
c'est sans précédent en fonction de
l'activité économique et sans l'accord
du maire donc prétendre comme vous le
faite qu'il y a
affaiblissement du faudra conclure est
une erreur je m'inscris en faux contre
cela la poste est en train d'être
modernisé mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
elle n'a jamais été aussi proche des
français
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant président philippe adnot pour
la réunion administrative des sénateurs
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
je vous remercie monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur
richerdt ministre en responsabilité des
collectivités territoriales et l appel
de sa part une confirmation du caractère
purement indicatif du seuil de 5000
habitants qui a été mentionnée à
l'article l 52 10 du nouveau code
général des collectivités territoriales
issu de la loi de réforme des
collectivités que nous avons votée
récemment même si chacun sait ce que je
pense de ce texte
en tout cas c'est ce qui est en train de
s'appliquer et le sens de la lettre de
la loi porte bien ce seuil haut rang des
orientations à prendre en compte par le
schéma départemental de coopération
intercommunale tel en est aussi et c'est
ce que je souhaite monsieur ne mise que
vous puissiez nous assurer l'esprit
qu'il s'agisse en effet des travaux
préparatoires à la réforme des
déclarations faites par monsieur le
premier ministre à l'occasion du congrès
des maires indiquant très clairement
qu'il s'agissait là de quelque chose qui
avait un caractère non et non impératif
et non normatif je souhaite que ce soit
réaffirmé la maxime latine qu'avait
utilisé votre prédécesseur dans cet
hémicycle et qui consistait à montrer
que les actes ou les contrats doivent
être entendus ou compris dans le sens où
ils produisent un effet
et dans celui où ils n'ont aucun
résumait bien la portée purement
indicative de ce texte
monsieur le ministre cette souplesse
demandé est actée par le parlement a été
longuement débattue dans cet hémicycle
elle trouve son fondement dans la dans
les différentes réalités démographiques
5000 euros cinq mille habitants
ça veut rien dire dans la région
parisienne mais dans mon département où
il ya des secteurs à 12 habitants au
kilomètre carré
ça n'a aucun sens de vouloir avoir une
seule et même règle et donc vous avez
fait une circulaire en décembre 2010
elle donne au préfet les premières
indications elle rappelle qu'il s'agit
d' orientation
malheureusement elle est aussi bien plus
restrictive et elle est comprise
localement d'une manière directives et
les retours que nous avons tous ici tous
mes collègues qui nous sont rapportés
est bien c'est qu'on essaye de forcer la
main aux élus et donc moi ce que
j'attends de votre part monsieur le
ministre c'est que vous confirmiez qu'il
s'agissait bien de quelque chose
d'indicatif que vous nous vous vous
engagiez à le redire à l'ensemble des
footeux terminé j'en ai terminé et que
le seuil n'est donc pas obligatoire mais
qu'il est indicatif nous serions
agréablement intéressé monsieur le
ministre à ce que vous le confirmer pour
vous répondre la parole à monsieur
philippe richert ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales la passion
chez le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le président
philippe adnot dans la très grande
majorité des départements les préfets
ont présenté à la commission
départementale de coopération
intercommunale
un projet de schéma qui propose
d'atteindre les objectifs que nous avons
assignés à la réforme de la carte
intercommunale
parmi ces objectifs le principal est de
faire en sorte que les périmètres de cep
s'ils correspondent mieux aux bassins de
vie qu'ils administrent c'est
l'efficacité qui est en cause parmi ses
objectifs
c'est d'atteindre au minimum 5000
habitants dans les regroupements au
niveau de ces epc pour autant
je veux repréciser ici ce qui a été
clairement dit lors des débats c'est que
c'est un objectif que nous souhaitons
atteindre mais que cet objectif souffre
notamment d'exception en particulier 2
la première c'est pour les zones de
montagne et la deuxième c'est lorsqu'il
y à des situations particulières qui
peuvent le justifier
dans les départements comme par exemple
la densité démographique je veux redire
ici puisqu'on parlait de citation
citation de joseph joubert qui disait le
but n'est pas toujours placé pour être
atteint mais pour servir de point de
mire c'est un peu ce que nous pouvons
comprendre au travers de ce que le
parlement et le gouvernement cros
produit en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne ses opci de 5000 habitants de
5000 habitants au minimum permettez moi
pour terminer simplement de redire ici
que nous souhaitons par ailleurs que
dans ce travail qui est maintenant
engagée à partir du schéma soumis par le
préfet il ya trois mois de concertation
avec les ep c'est avec les communes et
quatre mois de débats à l'intérieur de
la commission départementale
c'est à dire que nous avons sept mois
devant nous et que ces sept mois doivent
être mis à contribution dans le cadre
d'un vrai dialogue
une vraie concertation pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions avoir dans le
maximum de cas une solution qui puisse
être accepté par les élus et par tout
simplement le préfet au travers de ce
qu'il représente
à savoir la traduction qui a été voulue
d'un texte que nous avons très largement
porté ensemble
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
qu'aujourd'hui au-delà des difficultés
ponctuelles ce qui doit nous réunir
c'est la volonté d'aller de l'avant et
de trouver des solutions dans le cadre
d'un débat que nous voulons constructif
voilà la réponse concrète que je
souhaite apporter à notre collègue
philippe à nous merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre d'état
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues il m'est
particulièrement agréable de saluer la
présence dans notre tribune d'honneur de
trois délégations de parlementaires la
première de l'assemblée nationale de la
république
du congo conduite par monsieur sylvette
hausse si allah président de la
commission de l'économie et des finances
la délégation ayant été accueillis au
sida par notre collègue christophe andré
frassa la deuxième de collègues députés
slovènes conduit là vous venez
d'assister à la session des questions au
gouvernement
nous on refait la séance dans quelques
secondes on refait la séance sur public
sénat juste à côté de l'hémicycle avec
nous sur le plateau marie-anne montchamp
bonjour bonjour vous êtes secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités et de la cohésion sociale
avec vous on va aborder tout un certain
nombre de thèmes mais je voudrais tout
d'abord abordé cette question
d'actualité qui agite notamment la
majorité au sujet du rsa et des propos
de laurent wauquiez qui a dit que
l'assistanat est l un des cancers de
notre société ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ses propos sur ce sujet la
polémique est close
en revanche ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que la polémique la polémique est
close
le chef de l'état le premier ministre
ont souhaité apaiser une situation qui
nous renvoie un sujet intéressant qu'est
ce que c'est dans la france de 2011
qu'un minimum social à quoi ça doit
servir ça doit servir à lutter contre la
pauvreté tout à l'heure au zénith
bachelot l'a très bien rappelé ça doit
servir aussi à nos compatriotes qui sont
le plus éloignés de la vie sociale le
plus éloignés de l'emploi a retrouvé le
chemin de la vie sociale d'une capacité
à travailler bref d'un rétablissement
sociale et l'esprit du rsa c'est
celui-là c'est celui de conjuguer art
venu à une capacité à rebondir et les
français sont très en attente de cette
capacité mais laurent wauquiez qui
s'était exprimée encore une fois dans le
journal le progrès ce matin qui est
revenu sur ses propos qui a affirmé ses
propos et je pense qu'il a voulu aller
un petit peu plus loin et notamment sur
l'assistanat jean françois copé l'a
rejoint en les disant que l'assistanat
serait un des enjeux majeurs de la
campagne de 2012 vous êtes d'accord vous
qu'il y avait une fibre très social est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça si
vous voulez ce que j'observe c'est que
quelque chose nous différencie des
politiques sociales de gauche dans la
majorité présidentielle et à travers
toutes les réformes sociales du
quinquennat nous n'avons cessé
d'affirmer que nous croyons à la
capacité de l'individu à se rétablir
socialement a retrouvé meilleure fortune
pour cela il faut que la collectivité
soit active c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'elles apportent des aides qui sont
les minima sociaux notamment
mais ça ne suffit pas on ne peut pas
faire taire en quelque sorte nos
compatriotes qui sont sur le bord de la
route en leur disant écoutez vous
émarger à un guichet social ça suffit il
faut en même temps leur donner la
capacité de ce rétablissement
et ce rétablissement brasparts des
politiques de santé quand ils sont
frappés par la maladie par des
politiques de compensation ans qu'ils
sont frappés par le handicap et par des
politiques sociales d'inclusion sociale
de retour à l'emploi
quand ils sont effectivement éloigné de
la vie sensible aux champs c'est un
sujet qui risquent beaucoup de
clivé pendant la campagne électorale
est-ce que vous pensez que la l'ump a
voulu s'engager sur une voie
peut-être une voie sans issue je crois
que l'ump a ouvert un débat
et comme toujours au serbe j'observe
qu'il est normal que le parti
majoritaire engage des débats sur des
sujets qui sont de véritables sujets de
société nous ne pouvons pas nous
résigner à ce que la question sociale
soit une forme des thés noirs des
problèmes de société nous devons
apporter à nos compatriotes des réponses
effectivement soutien financier mais
également en récupération sociale
dernière question sur ce sujet avant de
parler de la dépendance
gérard larcher le président du sénat
qu'on a entendues dans l'hémicycle tout
à l'heure c'était intervenu ce matin sur
une radio et il a dit laurent wauquiez
était allé trop loin et qu'il devrait
peut-être en tirer les conclusions
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce que
est ce que laurent wauquiez doit on
tirer les conclusions
vous savez je vais vous dire quand on
est mal compris ou insuffisamment
compris il faut évidemment se poser des
questions mais ne restons pas sur
l'écumé des jours
allons regarder ceux qui derrière ces
sociétés dossier pardon et ses sujets
interroge notre société et moins jeunes
servent qu'effectivement nous devons à
nos compatriotes qui sont fragilisés
non seulement un soutien mais encore
plus que ça la confiance de la
collectivité pour les aider à se
rétablir
monchamp vous êtes en charge d'un des
dossiers avec roselyne bachelot sur la
dépendance qui sera sûrement l'un des
enjeux majeurs aussi des futures années
et notamment sera un des chantiers du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy ou est-ce
que vous en êtes aujourd'hui on va
parler du financement dans un instant
mais sur le terrain concrètement vous en
êtes où eh bien écoutez nous avons
devant nous une grande feuille de route
avec 26 débats interdépartementaux
quatre débats interrégionaux
je suis personnellement comme roselyne
bachelot à la moitié de ce tour de
france
et déjà nous avons capté de la part de
nos compatriotes de la part des
professionnels des remontées extrêmement
intéressante et précise sur la manière
d'aborder ce sujet sur le financement
les pistes de financement il n'y aura eu
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
on va augmenter la csg ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus
ce qui est certain c'est que à l'automne
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et du
projet de loi de finances nous
résoudrons les tensions qui existent sur
notre modèle aujourd'hui mais qu'il nous
faudra questionner notre modèle
d'accompagnement de la dépendance si
nous voulons être capables d'apporter
les bonnes réponses en qualité mais
aussi des réponses pérennes sur le plan
financier et moi mon champ mais juste
une dernière précision est ce que par
exemple il faudrait une deuxième journée
de solidarité est ce qu'il faut
augmenter la csg ce sont des vraies
questions ce sont des financements ce
que vous avez les réponses des jeux sont
des questions il y à quelques principes
essentiels
le président de la république les a
rappelés une manière très précise pas
question de peser sur le coût du travail
est de fragiliser notre économie pas
question non plus de financé par le
déficit ce qui relève de notre
responsabilité collective
il va donc falloir avoir de
l'imagination et répondre en qualité à
ce qu est aujourd'hui un débat de serre
si beaucoup moins montchamp d'être venu
sur d'autres plateaux et nous a rejoint
une autre mini chantal jouanno
bonjourbonjour ministre des sports une
grande question a agité ces derniers
temps votre ministère et également toute
la classe du football français du sport
et du sport en général bien entendu on
va en parler si vous le voulez bien
et cet après midi devait se tenir une
réunion très importante
la fédération française de football
conseil fédéral est ce que vous en savez
plus sur ce qui s'est déroulé dans cette
instance
je ne sais absolument pas ce qui s'est
déroulé à la danse dans les
installations jeu le sourire mon avis qu
en fin de
enfin est-ce que vous vous attendez
quelque chose aujourd'hui c'est une
réunion conciliation si on peut dire le
principe est assez simple c'est qu'en
termes de respect de la loi
les deux missions d'inspection ont
montré qu'il y avait pas de faits
objectifs qui permettent de dire on va
saisir la justice parce qu'il n'y a pas
eu respect de la loi par contre c'est
vrai qu'en interne il y a eu une réunion
désastreuse avec des propos extrêmement
déplacé même des idées déplacés qui une
réunion qui était pas du tout à la
hauteur de ce qu'on pouvait attendre
donc on attend de la fédération qu'elle
prenne des décisions des décisions
termes d'organisation interne d'audit de
management et des décisions
éventuellement en terme de sanction mais
qui ne lui appartiennent qu à elle je
n'ai pas de pouvoir sur les personnes
qui ne sont pas de mon ministère
vous avez dit vous avez dit qu'il y
avait pas de problème avec n'était pas
là effectivement pour couper des têtes
non mais vous êtes ministre des sports
de tutelle donc c'est à vous aussi de
prendre des sanctions ou des décisions
s'il devait y en avoir
je peux prendre des sanctions ou des
décisions quand il ya atteinte à la loi
je ne peux pas m'ingérer dans le
fonctionnement interne de la fédération
les personnes qui sont en cause dans ce
débat a pas une personne
les personnes qui sont en cause ne sont
pas sous contrat de travail le ministère
ne sont pas sous ma tutelle et notamment
le directeur le fameux directeur
technique national monsieur blaquart en
fait il est nommé par le président de la
fédération après avis du ministre des
sports il a été nommé donc le fait de
aujourd'hui lui retirer ses fonctions
appartient à la fédération et toute
ingérence toute ingérence du ministère
dans le fonctionnement interne serait
automatiquement condamné par la fifa par
l'uefa par les journalistes sportifs par
le mouvement sportif
on est là sur quelque chose d'ailleurs
que pas très simple parce qu'on publie
des missions de service public à des
fédérations et on voit bien qu'en
réalité on n'a pas vraiment les moyens
de contrôler ce qui se passe et
d'ailleurs quand j'ai été nommé quelques
semaines après
j'ai demandé une mission d'inspection
conjointe de notre ministère et du
ministère des finances pour justement
voir comment l'argent public est utilisé
comment on rend compte de cette mission
de service public et comment nous
pourrions avoir des sanctions plus
organisé quand vous parlez de service
public si on peut les aime tout petit
peu plus loin vous voulez dire que le
football est un service public en tout
cas la fédération est un service public
elle a donc des comptes à rendre le
football comme tous les sports et
participe à des missions marginales
sport roi le football sport roi mais
tous les sports participent aux missions
d'intérêt général on les finance à
l'échelle nationale on les finance
localement on à moi j'ai plus
d'effectifs dans les fédérations qu'au
sein de mon propre ministère donc et ça
en échange effectivement missions
d'intérêt général et de service public
d'abord le rayonnement de la france donc
le sport de haut niveau
mais surtout et peut-être plus encore
aujourd'hui une émission de cohésion de
lutte contre les discriminations donc
ils ont aujourd'hui des comptes à nous
rendre sur ces sujets et on verra les
décisions qu'ils prendront et enfonce du
conseil fédéral où les attendait avec
impatience les attend avec impatience et
en fonction de ça on adaptera notre
propre fonctionnement mais vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure ça touche le sport en
général vous sentez là un problème de
discrimination est ce que vous allez
lancer quelque chose à son compte
on voit bien que c'est extrêmement
malsain de s'imaginer qu'on puisse
mettre des quotas en fonction des
origines en fonction de la nationalité
ou de la couleur de peau dans le sport
c'est contraire à l'éthique du sport qui
veut qu'on sélectionne les meilleurs
physiquement et mentalement
et comme l'a très bien dit d'ailleurs
laurent blanc dans cette réunion
je reprends ses termes il a dit moi si
j'ai une équipe une équipe entre élimé
de blacks ça me va très bien
dès lors qu'ils aiment l'équipe de
france et qu'ils ont envie de jouer pour
la france et c'est ça le seul sujet qui
vaut la peine d'être posée c'était le
problème des binationaux mais il ya
aussi
entraîneur qui doit qui se doit de
respecter sa parole il ya un entraîneur
qui se doit de respecter sa parole il ya
des joueurs qui se doivent de respecter
le drapeau
c est ce que c'est le rôle d'un
entraîneur de l'équipe de france a'
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
d'être présent dans ce genre de réunion
il n'est jamais présente dans ce genre
de réunion c'est absolument exceptionnel
il est venu à la demande du directeur
technique national donc il était pas lui
d'ailleurs préparé au contenu du débat
un débat sur la question des quotas il
n'était pas préparé à ce débat donc je
pense pas qu'il y retourne honnêtement
une question sur les sénatoriales ce
matin le président du sénat gérard
larcher a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas être
parlementaires à mi temps vous êtes
candidate pour les sénatoriales vous
êtes ministre des sports quel sera votre
choix qu'allez vous faire
est-ce que l'on comptait démissionner je
suis candidate aux sénatoriales pour
être sénateur ou plus exactement
sénatrice et donc après la question du
maintien au gouvernement elle ne
m'appartient pas elle n'appartient qu'au
premier ministre président de la
république et donc moi je suis très
simple je ferai ce qu'ils me disent mais
moi je suis candidate pour être
sénatrice mais candidatent aussi pour
rester ministre des sports au cas où je
suis on n'est jamais candidat pour
rester ministre des sports au poste
ministre
je suis candidate pour être sénatrice
points maintenant la composition du
gouvernement elle ne m'appartient pas ni
rester ni ni partir mais ça je pense que
c'est une erreur de dire je suis
candidate pour être ministre on n'est
jamais candidat pour être ministre ça
nous appartient pas merci beaucoup aux
chantal jouanno ministre des sports
merci nous avons rejoint sur le plateau
de public sénat et maintenant
à ma gauche évidemment françois rebsamen
vous êtes un sénateur de côte-d'or du
parti socialiste est pour ça que j'ai
précisé à ma gauche
vous avez entendu toute cette polémique
autour du rsa et des propos de laurent
wauquiez
le parti socialiste va t-il se saisir de
cette polémique pour augmenter encore
une fois cette polémique est montée
encore d'un créneau ou au contraire vous
comptez un petit peu rétro pédaler et
bien c'est une erreur où on accepte et
on s'arrête là non bien sûr c'est une
erreur c'est une erreur qui est
aujourd'hui reconnue par le premier
ministre mais ce qui me frappe le plus
c'est cette cette obsession
gouvernementales à stigmatiser les gens
qui ont le moins de revenus à travers
les propos et les traiter j'ai même eu
des mots qui est sont très violents
cancer de la société ce robot de
l'assistanat
oui alors que aujourd'hui c'est pas les
personnes les plus pauvres qui sont
assistés des personnes les plus riches
elles ont assisté par le gouvernement
ils assistent ce gouvernement permanence
les personnes les plus riches pour faire
en sorte qu'elle paye moins d'impôts
donc c'est c'est un dévoiement total
aujourd'hui de l'esprit de solidarité
qui doit régner la république il n'est
pas concevable de pointé du doigt comme
ça celles et ceux qui ont du mal à vivre
à survivre 7 millions de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est
pas c'est pas concevable mois pour un
républicain je le crois de les pointer
du doigt et des rouelles cancer la
société c'est l'assistanat et vous
sentir c'est vrai clivage entre le parti
socialiste et l'ump
je pense qu'ils traversent également
l'ump c'est mon sentiment je pense que
il y a au sein de l'ump des personnes
qui sont les républicains qui sont
choqués par ces propos parce que ça
touche aux fondements de la république
comment peut-on concevoir moi qui suis
maire par les employés aujourd'hui dans
nos centres d'action sociale
on reçoit des personnes qui n'arrivent
pas à finir les fins de mois je veux pas
faire du misérabilisme quand je vous dis
ça c'est la vérité qui n'arrive pas à
payer leurs factures edf qui n'arrive
pas à payer leur loyer qui sont
surendettés on les reçoit on en reçoit
de plus en plus malheureusement
tout le monde aimerait qu'il y en ait
moins et les pointer du doigt en disant
voilà il ya un problème un cancer
l'assistanat
non c'est pas d'assistanat il aimerait
bien pouvoir travailler c'est le travail
qu'il faudrait leur donne je vous coupe
et je renvoie la balle directement vers
le premier ministre ancien premier
ministre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation jean pierre raffarin vice
président du sénat est-ce que vous aussi
vous avez le sentiment qu'avec cette
polémique qui a été créée par l'euro
vaut qu'est une certaine catégorie de
personnes ont été pointés du doigt je
pense qu'il faut pas s'attarder sur les
polémiques et moi je ne veux pas
participer à cette polémique
au fond le rsa tout le monde sait très
bien que c'est un processus utile mais
c'est une démarche complexe et il faut
après que nous l'ayons mis en oeuvre il
faut l'analyser et l'améliorer parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y à sa tombe des faits
qui ne sont pas positives et d'autres
qui sont très positifs le rsa a été fait
pour permettre un certain nombre de gens
de sortir de la trappe à pauvreté et on
se rend compte que ya un certain nombre
de situations qui sont positives et
qu'il faut corriger un certain nombre de
défauts donc il ne faut pas en faire
trop sur ce sujet mais à voir l'ardeur
que mais le parti socialiste à défendre
le rsa je trouve que c'est un des
mérites de cette polémique de rappeler
que le parti socialiste a quand même pas
voter le rsa donc c'est vers vous que ce
que se retourne la question finalement
martin hirsch avait proposé le ca
pendant la grève
la campagne de 2007 et donc nous avons
soutenu la démarche de martin hirsch
après les modalités ne nous plaisait pas
peut-être parce qu'ils avaient les
imperfections bien soulever jean pierre
raffarin
mais sur le fond l'idée est bien sûr
porté par martin hirsch était
intéressante et personne ne l'a niée
donc moi ce que je pointait du doigt
tout à l'heure c'était cette faculté qui
existent aujourd'hui au sein de ce
gouvernement de cliver notre société de
chercher toujours opposés les uns aux
autres et je sais que ça choque à
l'intérieur de la majorité est en cause
c'est un appel à la cohésion sociale
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui c'est pas
d'appel à la division et au climat
je suis désolé mais je suis obligé merci
beaucoup c'est vous devez partir
d'archivés jean haxaire justement
parlons de l'ump ce matin dans un
journal où dans un quotidien le figaro
pour pas le nommer vous avez dit qu'il
fallait inventer une nouvelle rupture
est ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
que vous vouliez déclaré par nouvelle
rupture
je pense que l'élection de 2012 ne sera
pas déterminé par la situation de 2007
mais plutôt par la situation de 2015
c'est à dire moi ce que je crois c'est
qu'il faut d'abord identifier les grands
enjeux de la société française il y en a
plusieurs
il ya un enjeu européen puisque l'europe
est aujourd'hui menacé qu'on a un enjeu
de cohésion sociale on a un enjeu
éducatif
il ya aussi un enjeu moral dans la
société sur les valeurs morales et je
pense que les élections doivent se
définir comme une réponse à des enjeux
donc plutôt que de partir de la
situation de 2007 je crois qu'il faut
regarder quels sont les crises qui sont
devant nous et comment apporter des
réponses à ces crises
de ce point de vue là j'ai le sentiment
que nicolas sarkozy et l'équipe de
nicolas sarkozy peuvent être la
meilleure réponse à ces enjeux
encore faut-il expliquer aux français
les enjeux qui concernent leur avenir
mais est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
on regarde assez vers l'avenir
quant aux locaux quand nicolas sarkozy
la semaine dernière où françois fillon
ont fait leur bilan 4 en bilan des mots
c'est un peu un retour en arrière on
regarde le passé on ne se projette pas
vers l'avenir
c'est donc c'est dommage qu'on ne
regarde pas à celles à venir mais le
gouvernement est dans son rôle de faire
son bilan comme comme tout le monde le
r fait son bilan le plein de conseil
général ait fait son bilan donc à pas du
moment vous avez été lu vous rendez
compte
mais ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est non
seulement de regarder l'avenir mais
c'est aussi d'ouvrir sur les nouvelles
générations
quand vous prenez un sujet comme
l'environnement par exemple
l'environnement c'est travailler pour
les générations futures
mais quand vous prenez la question de la
dette et la réduction de la dette c'est
aussi travaillé pour les générations
futures qui supporteront c'est peut-être
qu'on confond il faut s'ouvrir et au
lieu de je pense de santé trop à vouloir
expliquer le passé il faut anticiper
l'avenir et apporter les réponses à cet
appel pour nicolas sarkozy le futur
candidat pour qu'il se projette vers
l'avenir
moi je pense que c'est en se projetant
sur les difficultés que nous devons
affronter qu'on trouvera les réponses
est ce que nicolas sarkozy a de plus
fort par rapport à ses concurrents c'est
à la fois son expérience est aussi
intelligente et je pense que s'il se
définit non pas par rapport à son
histoire personnelle mais par rapport
aux enjeux de la société
il peut être en 2012 la bonne réponse
dernière question rapidement jean pierre
raffarin le parti radical se réunit ce
week-end jean louis borloo pourrait
annoncer dans ces cas-là divorce à
l'amiable avec l'ump quitter l'ump
peut-être se porter candidat à la
présidentielle
c'est pour vous un échec de l'ump ou
est-ce qu'au contraire vous voyez ça
d'un bon oeil on va voir il ya deux
sujets différents
la candidature je crois que c'est une
question anticipées d'une manière
générale tous ceux qui jouent la carte
de l'anticipation
le regretteront car l'anticipation d'une
élection ça dessert toujours ce qu'ils
utilisent cette démarche en revanche
qu'il y ait besoin de renouveler le
centre c'est vrai que le centre a
toujours été dans la vie politique
française un élément déterminant mais la
plateforme du centre qu'avait fédérer et
valéry giscard d'estaing que ce soit la
décentralisation que ce soit l'europe
pour les idées libérales sur le plan
économique il est clair que ses idées
sont aujourd'hui dans le patrimoine de
l'ump donc il ya de nouvelles idées
aujourd'hui il y à la proximité il ya
l'environnement le développement durable
la croissance zéro pour son candidat
thür je pense qu'avant la candidature il
faut trouver le message et je pense que
le centre le centre sans frontières que
ce soit le centre dans l'ump le sang à
côté de l'ump
le sentent en dehors de la majorité il y
à du centre aujourd'hui par tout ce qui
compte
et si jean louis borloo veut être utile
c'est d'essayer de participer à cette
rénovation de la pensée du centre une
fois que la pensée du centre sera
renouvelée rénové on pourra envisager
son expression personnellement je suis
favorable à une expression du centre
dans l'ump
mais la question aujourd'hui c'est la
question de l'aide de l'idée de cette
rénovation des idées du centre et donc
je pense que jean louis borloo mais
françois bayrou
mais morin et d'autres tombes ont peu
plein de choses à dire aujourd'hui et il
faut le dire sans oublier les centristes
les libéraux et les européens de l'ump
merci monsieur prémunissent mercedes
intervenu sur public sénat l'avait un
successeur ici voilà qui rend compétents
la personne dans la bouche et alain
fouché
merci pour la présentation alain fouché
sénateur de la vienne
vous êtes un spécialiste aussi des
questions on va dire de sécurité
routière sur un sens large
hier s'est tenu un conseil national sur
la sécurité routière il ya eu des
décisions prises des décisions qui vont
dans un sens plutôt bon ou pas pour vous
donnez vos peut-être rappeler que au
moment de la loi loppsi bon il ya eu des
amendements qui ont été votés pour
l'assouplissement du permis à points
donc qui n'ont aucun rapport avec le
taux d'accidents mais en même temps il a
été pris un certain nombre de mesures en
ce qui concerne les accidents graves
notamment les chauffards ceux qui
conduisent sous l'état d'alcoolémie ceux
qui conduisent
avec de la drogue ont des mesures très
précises ont été prises déjà tel
renforcement des amendes et des peines
de prison pour ces grandes infractions
mirabelli si jamais on dépasse de 50
km/heure de ce qui était déjà il ya
quelques mois déjà qu'ils étaient mis en
place c'est le fn fort pour le trafic de
points ces confiscations des voitures
ses démarrages des voitures après t-il
aux tests dont il ya toute une batterie
de mesures qui est épris l'un de
nouvelles mesures ont été prises
il y en a pas les rappeler rapidement
ainsi jamais on dépasse de 50 km/heure
ça devient un délit
évidemment paraît tout à fait normal
évidemment en état d'ivresse sanctionner
un état d'ivresse supérieur à 0,25
sanctionnée de 8 points au lieu de six
actuellement
aussi une décision importante c'est de
supprimer les panneaux indiquant les
radars est la suivante peuvent pas
forcément d'accord je crois mais je ne
suis pas tout à fait d'accord il
yad'autres l'écriture d'accord
l'alcoolémie le téléphone à la main
droite mais par contre sur les radars
sont les radars c'est quoi c'est une
machine à faire du fric chacun le sait
c'est une pompe à fric
bon si je reprends les propos que tenait
le président de la république il ya
quelques années lorsqu'il était ministre
de l'intérieur il avait dit qu'il
fallait laisser cette cet affichage ces
panneaux il fallait avoir cette
nécessaire transparence pour éviter le
sentiment d'être piégés donc je trouve
aujourd'hui qu'avec ces panneaux des
quantités de gens vont être pris des
gens qui vont être à 58 aux 60 au lieu
de 50
il faut savoir qu'à 60 par exemple si
vous contestez l'amendement tribunal si
vous devez pas prouvée le chi kong et
votre véhicule nous peut avoir une
amende de 750 euros ou des retraits de
points
donc ce sont les gens qui font des
petits trajets tous les jours qui vont
se faire prendre
ceux qui sont plus riches pour acheter
des points donc en définitive c'est les
gens les plus faibles alors ne trouve
pas que cette mesure soit une bonne
mesure et lé risque de très nombreux
française que vous dire le reste ça
passe mais celle ci hérite de nombreux
français et je crois que le gouvernement
c'est une erreur
je pense que c'est c'est une erreur
parce que c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut
arrêter la sécurité la sécurité c'est en
faisant des formations c'est et non pas
en sans arrêt en mettant des amendes
c'est surtout en faisant des formations
en essayant de mettre les jeunes qui
passent leur permis sur des circuits
terrain qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
donc je pense qu'il faut faire un effort
d'éducation
tout ceci est une question de
comportement il faut habituer les gens à
avoir ce comportement et c'est parce
qu'on fait pillards l'état des routes
qui n'est pas bon globalement il ya
d'autres aussi le fait qu'ils sont pas
qu'ils sont pas au point je dire d'un
effort un effort d'éducation merci
beaucoup à l'affiché des trains prévus
sur notre plateau adrien gouteyron nous
a rejoint bonsoir ou bonjour pardon
sénateur ump de haute-loire et vous
voulez nous parler d'un sujet qui est
très important pour la france
actuellement
car la france et connaît à tout
sécheresse comme jamais nous avons
connue pour panne depuis près depuis
près de 100 ans et les principaux les
principales filières qui sont touchés ce
sont les éleveurs les agriculteurs
notamment
est ce qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui
déclenché un plan d'urgence je pense
qu'on ne peut pas rester insensible à
cette situation vous l'avez dit
vous-même effectivement cette situation
est très grave
on a connu des sécheresses dans le passé
tout le monde a en tête la sécheresse de
1976 qui a été absolument terrible celle
de cette année
l'êtes aussi donc il faut pas faire de
comparaisons game fr comparaison c'est
vrai que ces données nous sommes à peine
au mois de mai nous sommes la chesnaie
l'animé c'est déjà ce sera trop tard
vous assurer que j'ai eu dans mon
département du témoignage qui ont
beaucoup touché récemment j'ai lu
un agriculteur venir vers moi et me dire
qu'ils ne savaient plus qu'ils ne
savaient plus comment nourrir son bétail
qui ne pouvaient tout n'a plus les
moyens il n'a pas les moyens d'acheter
du fourrage il n'a plus rien on peut pas
rester insensible
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est
ce que le gouvernement doit faire je
pense que il faut tout de même prévoir
un certain nombre de dispositifs et il
faut leur permettre d'acheter des
forages parce que les forages sont
disponibles il faut souvent aller les
chercher doit d'ailleurs c'est pas
évident la bridoire ils ont le rire a
indiqué a indiqué qu'il pourrait libérer
ces fourrages et qu'il n'y aurait pas et
qu'ils allaient libérer des terres mises
en jachère qui auront été récemment mise
en misant la chair c'est une mesure mais
elle sera certainement insuffisante
compte tenu de la gravité du problème
je crois que le il appartient au
gouvernement maintenant de mettre en
place une batterie de mesures en
négociation comme cela se passe dans
cette profession en négociation avec les
syndicats agricoles
moi je suis persuadé qu'il faut aller
très vite
c'est d'autant plus grave que la
situation des exploitations agricoles et
on le sait dans notre pays pour beaucoup
d'entre elles extrêmement fragile leur
trésorerie
son exemple et ils n'ont pas les moyens
d'acheter du fourrage dont qu'ils
auraient besoin et parce qu'il faut
aller les chercher très loin
donc il faut trouver adrien gouteyron
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer un impôt
sécheresse qu'a décidé en urgence je ne
sais pas s'il faut en impôt sécheresse
parce que le l'expression même révulse
un peu les citoyens l'impôt fait peur
mais il faut pas stigmatiser une
profession il faut pas dresser les
français les uns contre les autres et
c'est ce serait une mauvaise manière mes
romans je suis persuadé qu'il faut que
la solidarité nationale joue et qu'elle
joue à plein dans ces circonstances
c'est l'intérêt des intérêts c'est bien
sûr de la nécessaire vis-à-vis des
intéressés eux mêmes des agriculteurs
mais c'est nécessaire pour le pays
n'oublions pas que l'agriculture est
pour nous un capital économique
extrêmement important alors écoutez rond
merci merci d'être venu sur le plateau
de public sénat
jack ralite nous a rejoints bonjour jack
ralite vous êtes sénateurs du groupe
communiste et membre de la commission de
la culture est avec vous peut-être vous
allez nous parler de robespierre robes
spa il ya eu des manuscrits qui ont été
retrouvés ces manuscrits seront mis en
vente par la société sotheby's le 18 mai
prochain
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce
qu'il ya dans ces manuscrits c'est quand
même presque révolutionnaire si on peut
parler de robespierre des documents qui
ont été gardés par la femme du
conventionnel le bord qui était un ami
de robespierre au moment de l'exécution
de robespierre
donc pendant deux siècles et demi la
famille bas à garder ces documents
s'agissant 13 feuillets une partie c'est
la correspondance que lui a adressée à
andré spire son frère et une autre
partie qui colle alors à 1794
c'est
c'est des bosses de son discours au
moment où il a été condamné à mort et
exécuté
c'est donc quelque chose de très
sensible de très important qui a marqué
l'histoire de france et d'un seul coup
ça apparaît sur le marché et c'est quand
même quelque chose d'époustouflant que
l'on veuille vendre quelque chose qui
vienne de l'incorruptible alors alors
qu'ils pourraient racheter ces documents
on met ya toujours des gens d'autant
qu'ils s'agitent documents je dirais
chaud on n'a rien parce que tout était
jetée à ce moment là les gens détestait
enfin des gens une minorité n'a été
suffisante pour le détester et tout a
été jeté donc ça nous revient deux
siècles un peu plus de deux siècles
après et s'est mis sur le marché
alors la tâche d'un état qui respecte
ses responsabilités patrimoniale
c'est d'empêcher que ça parte ailleurs
alors ils ont plusieurs moyens il ya le
moyen d'acheter comme tout un chacun il
ya le moyen de présenter au moment de
l'achat et puis elle moyen le plus
commode c'est de refuser un certificat
d'exportation des capitaux au quelqu'un
personne ne fait monter puisqu'il ne
pourra pas sortir l etat alors à 30 mois
pour régler la question
en tout cas on aura ces fragments de
mémoire nationale et historique
on en reparlera bien entendu sur public
sénat merci j'aimerais quand même nom
dire un petit mot c'est sûrement
broodwar aux nantais mais je vous en
prie résistant par beaucoup c'est
beaucoup de gens se sont mobilisés
les historiens de quelques tendances
qu'ils soient ceux de la société des
études robespierristes mais d'autres
trouvent qu'il est scandaleux de de
vendre le patrimoine est comme ça
devient une mode de vie en ce moment on
vend mont ventoux on vend des immeubles
on vote on veut vendre des toiles on
veut vendre des sculptures jack ralite
merci beaucoup merci d'être intervenu
sur notre antenne rendez vous bien sûr à
19h pour journal sur public sénat merci
et bonne fin de journée